any job that that debate cup for you
gang gang because second cousin is legal
first cousin is what is not legal and we
do have to get that out there because
there's a lot of mess improvement is
that the rule in Louisiana it's the rule
everywhere first cousin we look this up
to Nick you legally have sex you the
first cousin I know the answer's no but
we can do it problem you have answers no
information but you do the brother okay
you can never know Chappell yeah that's
do when you look like every one of your
stories so you should better start I can
have some information to support your
sex I hear Chappell okay some stage sex
between first cousins is prohibited in
some states yeah
legality of incest and look at that
color chart let's get to the color chart
we don't want to trick Brennan but
things in there literally not hey wifey
Oh knows the strict details on sleeping
with your cousin I have no idea are you
gonna blame it on meth again ass again
dude you don't know what you can do when
you're high
your cousins they're running low on
product you [ __ ] your cuz it dude
drug-induced assess you and I'm telling
you it's how it start you're gonna start
taking some responsibility for your
choices bro
now I'm just saying that do some places
you get the death penalty yeah that's
that Middle East area and also Africa
Middle East in some parts of Africa it
looks like frowned upon cans and Zabar
where is that what about in America can
we just look at America America is a
kind of orange and red on some of the
west coast just leaked out yeah let's
even just let's just go back to whatever
that first thing was this house is about
incest if we can incest laws and charges
the crime of incest is committed we know
what happens
is it is it a crime between adults what
about that almost all states criminalize
incest between adult relatives some
legal scholars have argued that incest
laws as apply to adults should be
rethought I see I could see that I think
a lot of it too because if you get with
a family member and you have a baby it
has a high likelihood of being a [ __ ]
up baby that's one of the main reasons
that's one of the main reasons man in
the United States what is this a nice
second cousin are legally allowed to
marry in every state praise God brother
well I'm just saying because here's one
of the things is some people they don't
live they used to not live close to
anybody like they didn't have cars they
didn't have so it's like you could only
you know you're not gonna walk over
probably 20 miles to have sex with
someone so you got to think and most of
that your family live enclosed so that's
why they made the laws was because yeah
babies were coming out a little while
Alabama allows first cousin marriage a
lot of them do Alaska
yes Arizona yes California yes
Colorado yes that's disappointing
Colorado did I would not [ __ ] my first
cousin at high altitude okay you are
really Louisiana apparently get some
sort of refund a few minutes wait very
first cousins is not allowed welcome to
the future brother we are laying the pad
that's why I feel move to television I'm
not gonna go home for Easter and this
Perona virus or because a warrant out
for your arrest sleep with you young
cousin what else you got last debate
club it's striking though but before we
do it Nick I want to go through and at
least answer some of these people's
questions because I don't think we've
answered any the guy said by the foot or
fruit Rolla
okay oh listen I'm more of a quality
over quantity the fruit by the foot it's
a foot [ __ ] long roll of [ __ ]
fruit roll-up it's like a cheap fruit
roll-up like that thick stiff fruit
roll-up
and you take it out of that package and
it's [ __ ] tight you roll that [ __ ]
out yeah and I still I still roll it up
she would stick to the roof like a
retainer I love that I never had a lie
we didn't have fruit roll-ups
they're expensive man they were
definitely more of a higher-end tree
they were fruit by the foot was cheap oh
you get that anywhere you get that on
the [ __ ] Street yeah you never did
have seven feet of it roll-ups always
advertise there is shapes inside it that
you could peel out and you can peel that
[ __ ] out no one ever did yeah you
could've held out to be all deformed all
do hard on ones end of the star or they
had the tongue tattoos yeah that's right
what was that they had like a little
imprint of like animals and stuff like
that where if you keep it on your tongue
for long enough you'll get like the
marking on your tongue so it looks like
a tattoo oh my god hey how about my son
and that sounds like a scam doesn't it
what kid would have kids will fall for
[ __ ] anything dude
dude how about Murray how about my son
got warheads for Easter oh yeah remember
warheads man I don't know they still
made a my son gun like what the [ __ ] do
they try them there's those little [ __ ]
warheads well they are not like when we
were kids more kids we eat those
warheads dude you gonna miss him for two
days oh the first batch of warheads that
ever came out for that hot batch dude
one of my friends had one and he
couldn't open his eyes for almost two
days couldn't open his eyes we had a ton
of stories like that we had to hold his
eyes open to look at him those war has a
different level some talks and but that
did the first ones that came out
somebody had one you have to split it up
I remember people would split it it'd
ruin your day yeah it was so much fun oh
yeah bro
remember I had like a little bit of dust
on the outside of that where can we get
those vintage warheads the remote
remember the big jaw breakers you'd lick
them so much your tongue would start to
bleed and you get to the middle and
there'd be like some weird gushy stuff
sauce no you never made it that far
this episode is discussing about sex and
perversion and this supposed to be our
Easter episode but hold on we haven't
helped anybody
yeah we did thank you hi I want the
[ __ ] roof riderhood some [ __ ]
okay I'm a fruit roll man okay I'll go
for fruit roll-ups and if I'm really
feeling froggy and I want to be get
savvy with it I'm going gushers all
goddamn day I put that gun off that
thing bus in my mouth oh oh that sweet
syrup rolls down my throat dude you
ain't Larabee's you start deep throwing
some gushers for help great gosh what
are you saying dude all great Guster's
look the same dude can't work with this
this is when is this stop bro
you own the Mexico an hour and it can I
sleep with my first costume you think
I'll be part of it I wouldn't offended
your hatch we need to let me see I told
you that it's legal dude I'm just saying
there are certain places have different
take will you tell your cousin equipment
[Music]
the king nothing
[Music]